the rm carp series to celebrate the
pioneering role of
simon's institute founding director dick
carp
in theoretical computer science and
we're grateful to the many contributors
to the richard m carp fund who've made
this series possible
the series features visionary leaders in
the field of theoretical computer
science
on topics associated with current
programs running at the simons institute
and it's geared towards a broad
scientific audience
so this semester the simon's institute
is hosting two
online programs one on probability
geometry and computation in high
dimensions
and one on the theory of reinforcement
learning and i'm delighted to welcome
our speaker today
professor dale shermans who's
participating in the program on the
theory of reinforcement learning
dale's a research scientist at google
brain and professor of computing science
at the university of alberta in edmonton
i've had the pleasure of knowing dale
for 25 years now he's famous for his
work across a range of areas in machine
learning and ai
including reinforcement learning online
learning bayesian optimization and
unsupervised learning
he's received paper awards at eurips
icml
ich kai and aaai and he's had a 10-year
canada research chair in machine
learning and
dale's a fellow of triple ai today we're
delighted to have him present a talk
entitled reductionism in reinforcement
learning
welcome dale thanks peter um
thanks for giving me this opportunity to
present to you
today um before i get started i do want
to acknowledge
many collaborators that are actually
responsible for most of the results
behind what i'm going to try to explain
today
most of these collaborators are based at
the university of alberta google brain
and also
summit d-bind okay
so my focus in this discussion is going
to be about reinforcement learning but
i'm going to share a little bit of an
idiosyncratic perspective
on this field this is now my third
independent attempt to try to make sense
out of reinforcement learning
um so i want to start with this holistic
view so when you
when you enter the field of
reinforcement learning you're probably
quickly confronted with this picture
which is we we pose the problem as
uh solving this agent environment
interaction task
where there's an agent it takes actions
it affects the state of the environment
receives feedback in the in the form of
observations and rewards
um now uh i actually find this picture
highly problematic
uh for the simple reason that it um
makes simple what is not simple it hides
many many complexities behind this
simple diagram
having to do with the nature of the
environment and also the agent's access
to that environment
moreover one quickly finds the field
seems to be dominated by what i will
call this kind of update based
algorithmic approach
where in synchronization with this
experience loop we're going to
learn or plan in this kind of
synchronous update kind of manner
i've just found it personally very
difficult to make progress with this
kind of holistic approach to the problem
so what i want to try to do a little bit
is advocate
a bit for a more reductive uh
perspective
so another way to to think about the
reinforcement learning problem
again at a high level is to think about
it you know quite simply as learning
decision making interactively
but to recognize that there are many sub
problems and many subfields involved in
this pursuit
for example we could just start uh by
focusing on decision-making itself which
is
a very important problem studied you
know in many areas
of computing science and engineering
under a
rubric of optimal control theory
decision theory so on and so forth
and there's a very rich hierarchy of
problem types there
and a diversity of solution concepts and
and a lot of you know
profound algorithmic achievements and
insights in solving decision making
which we normally express as a planning
problem where we're given a model and
we're just trying to compute like an
optimal
search algorithm or a compiled decision
strategy
now reinforcement learning is indeed
more ambitious than that we are
in addition to trying to solve something
like an optimal decision-making task
uh we're trying to do it on the basis of
not having the model known ahead of time
so instead of a model we get data you
know in the form of experience like
you know observation action reward next
observation uh experience sequences
um still given data we can you know
think of the problem as a learning
problem where we
could for example reduce it to decision
making by extracting a model from the
data and then
uh applying algorithmic concepts from
optimal decision making
or this very interesting possibility of
bypassing model construction going
straight to
trying to infer compiled solution
concepts in the form of a reactive
policy
or a value function um but reinforcement
learning is even more ambitious than
this
it doesn't just consider the problem of
learning decision making from a fixed
set of data
it actually considers the full loop
where we're also responsible for
collecting the data
that we then use to infer solution
concepts and this
loop here is the corresponding to that
simple agent environment interaction
but from this perspective i think one
can appreciate that there's there's a
significant amount of complexity behind
the overall problem
uh with many variations and many
subproblems involved
so um in by taking a reductionist stance
what i mean to say
is i've personally found it much more
productive and
meaningful to not take on the full loop
uh
or the full problem in one whole swoop
instead
it seems to me that i've found more
understanding and picking off and
isolating subproblems
of the overall picture and so my plan
today is just going to
be to share with you a couple of um
recent works
actually that where we've made progress
in understanding a couple of the
i think key sub problems um the first
part of the talk i'm just going to focus
on some recent work
which might seem quite uh unambitious
but is going to focus on the batch
single step decision making problem and
they're quite remarkably uh i i would
say that in the last two years there's
been amazing progress it's actually
quite stunning that we're still learning
an awful lot about this very basic core
problem
uh in reinforcement learning um once i
finished uh
that part i then i'm going to switch
gears a bit and also
try to share some yet even more recent
work on
understanding some basic issues in
learning in a sequential decision making
context
primarily focusing on how we're managing
the reasoning horizons
okay so let's start by considering the
single step decision making problem
quite simply what we're interested in
here is taking a collection of data
which i'm representing as a simple
matrix
uh and inferring a policy from this data
that we hope
works well on future data um to be a bit
more precise let's imagine our data is
given to us
in this kind of contextual bandit like
format where we have a set of contexts
x1 to xn that have somehow been measured
say for for simplicity of finite set of
actions a1 to am
and our data consists of there was a
context an
action was taken and a reward was
recorded for that action in that context
therefore in context x1 we took action
a2 we observe reward
r1 for example and our goal is to
process this set of data
and to produce a policy a policy here is
going to be a simply a map from context
to a probability vector across actions
denoted by pi
and we're going to work with a pretty
typical parameterization of policies
uh where instead of actually directly
learning the policy what we're going to
be concerned with
is learning what i'll call a score
function
here occluded at the bottom there
a score function q which for a given
context submits a score across
actions which is then converted to a
probability distribution by
exponentiating scores in the norm lines
uh otherwise known as the softmax
transfer which we'll deal with later
so our task is quite simple take this
data optimize the parameters of the
score function
that when converted to a policy uh you
know what
has a high probability of choosing good
actions or more precisely
uh in achieves high expected reward
not just on this training data but more
importantly on uh future
test contexts um
although it's somewhat simple to set
this problem up it turns out there are
many profound difficulties
from an algorithmic and uh inference
perspective when trying to solve this
problem
and i want to focus on two sub-problems
here um
the first sub-problem i'm going to talk
about is an even further simplification
where we just consider the optimization
or the training task associated with
this
kind of parameterized policy uh data
optimization setup
and then i'll back back up a bit and
then reconsider
how we might deal with missing data here
so first to focus on the optimization
problem um
to make things simple and to isolate
this task i'm going to temporarily
assume that we have complete data
so this is not very realistic but
imagine instead of just sparse data we
have
this kind of counter factual data
collection where for each context say x1
we have counterfactually gone back and
tried every different uh
alternative action in this context and
recorded the reward that you would have
gotten if you've taken this action in
that context
and build a complete training table over
a finite set of uh
contexts more like a supervised learning
uh setup where in fact we could even
assume high id context
now this does seem like a simple setup
and we could target a very natural and
straightforward objective
which is if we're trying to extract a
good policy uh from this data
we we would formulate the natural
objective which is let's
uh optimize or the policy parameters or
the score function parameters
uh simply the expected empirical reward
the average reward that that policy
would achieve on this data
and this seems pretty cut and dried it
seems like you know we've got a coherent
objective it's differentiable we could
just do gradient descent
and uh to send our way to victory um
turns out however that this is a very
challenging
uh uh task uh which is actually at the
heart of reinforcement learning uh
even uh you know it's it's easy to lose
sight of of this
uh core task when we look at much more
elaborate scenarios but it's sitting
there at the heart
uh and yet it turns out that this
objective has particularly serious
problems from an optimization
perspective
um maybe to reveal some of those
difficulties we uh if we just dig in a
little deeper we'll notice that actually
what we're trying to do is optimize the
parameters of the neural network which
is emitting the score vector across
actions
so we're really optimizing this middle
objective
which is r dot uh soft max transfer of
scores
this interaction of the dot product
between the rewards and the soft max
transfer
is actually very problematic from a an
optimization perspective
most serious problem is that it creates
plateaus if you exaggerate a score in a
particular action in the context
the uh the softmax transfer saturates
and you wind up getting
uh gradients that are near zero in fact
the uh the lance the optimization
landscape
has near zero gradients almost
everywhere um
even potentially worse than that is that
if your uh score function
parameterization is under complete in
any sense that is
you're not able to span uh arbitrary
policy vectors across
all contexts so you have some trade-offs
to make then you can quickly find uh
yourself in a situation where
from the perspective of the parameter
optimization
there are exponentially many local
maxima in the
optimization landscape in practice what
this simply means is that it's nearly
impossible
actually to directly optimize this
objective and find a good
solution even not even a near-optimal
solution
um okay but the point i want to make
here is is what's interesting about this
task is that we actually know in other
areas of machine learning and statistics
that this is
not a fruitful approach and in fact the
default approach this problem in other
related areas is quite different than
directly attacking the
expected reward optimization problem in
fact i would argue that most people on
this call if you've had any sort of
course or prior experience
machine learning you've no doubt learned
about supervised learning
you've already encountered a scenario
where you have had a problem like this
close to you but you've solved in a
different way
um to make this clear i'm going to
specialize the problem a little bit
temporarily
let's which is let's just imagine for
the sake of argument that the rewards in
that reward table
are simple 0-1 indicators where we have
a single one in each row
this is isomorphic to a supervised
classification problem where that one is
indicating the correct
label or action for the context or the
input example
for that for that kind of indicator
reward function
expected reward is nothing but expected
accuracy
so what we're we do indeed care a lot
about expected accuracy we would like
to maximize the expected accuracy of the
policy on future test data
but i'll just remind you that when
you're confronted with this problem
in a supervised learning context even
though you cared about expected accuracy
you did not optimize expected accuracy
when you're training the parameters of
the model
instead what you inevitably uh optimized
was
maximum likelihood log likelihood or put
more plainly
instead of maximizing r dot pi you
maximized r dot log pi
this is actually a very important
concept
which we just presume by default in
supervised learning
but is somehow a lesson that is less
prevalently appreciated in reinforcement
learning
um what's going on here well the fact is
we do care about accuracy
so often in supervised learning you do
indeed measure like misclassification
error on training data and this
classification your own test data
but we don't train by directly trying to
minimize misclassification error
instead we train by maximizing
likelihood the reason for this
is quite simple is uh well two reasons
one is the r dot log pi
objective is it still shares an
important relationship to the r dot pi
objective
in particular for any target value in r
dot pi
um there will always be some target
value in r dot log pi
for which the solution achieves that
desired target value in r dot pi
or put another way this proxy objective
or circuit
objective maximum likelihood is
calibrated with respect to the original
objective
in addition the maximum likelihood
objective is now convex or sorry concave
from a maximization perspective
concave in the uh score vector
emitted by the neural network this
essentially is like taking a very
difficult plateau riddled and possibly
local maxima riddled objective
and building a concave uh proxy
objective that's centered at the
at the peak this is so effective in fact
that in practice this is all we consider
in supervised learning
now if we just uh take this back to our
general reward case
we really still are thinking about a
supervised learning problem which is
known as context-sensitive
classification
and and the goal here would be to
essentially generalize maximum
likelihood
to a more general class of surrogate
objectives that allow us
to deal with arbitrary rewards not
simple indicator rewards
there has been work on developing
calibrated surrogates
for the subjective in the cost sensitive
classification setting
there's remarkably not a large
literature on this
and i would say that some of the results
are recent ish
but but nevertheless the problem has
been posed before uh what i want to
um just advocate for a little bit is a
very interesting systematic way
uh to develop surrogates in an intuitive
manner that's actually related to
maximum likelihood
um and the simple way to do this is by
introducing a small amount of entropy
regularization so
one could imagine taking expected reward
as a target objective but just adding
you know tau some temperature parameter
times entropy
uh of the policy as a regularizer for
the optimization
now entropy regularization by itself
does not really
uh mitigate the problems it simplifies
the landscape a little bit it does
accelerate training
but it actually doesn't really achieve
the same kind of benefits of maximum
likelihood
however once we express the exp entropy
regularized expected reward objective
uh we immediately find an interesting
mathematical structure that we can
exploit
in particular entropy regularized
expected reward maximization is
isomorphic to minimizing a kl divergence
between your policy output and an
implicit target distribution p
where the implicit target distribution p
is defined by exponentiating the
reward vector perhaps pre-scaling it by
a temperature parameter tau
and then normalizing what's interesting
about this setup well there's many
reasons why it's interesting but
one of the key things that's interesting
about this is it sets up a relationship
between a score vector and a policy
probability vector
and a reward vector and a target
distribution vector
so we get this kind of duality where we
can simultaneously
simultaneously think in the score or
reward space or the policy and
probability space
i'll come back to this later so entropy
regularized expected board maximization
is nothing but minimizing the kl
divergence
in the mode seeking direction minimizing
the kl of pi
and p to this implicit reference
distribution p
once we're looking at kl divergence
minimization there is now a completely
natural and obvious way to generate
a concave surrogate objective simply by
considering the reverse
direction of the kl which goes from a
mode seeking to a mode covering
orientation
um the reversed kl now is an objective
that is
as before convex uh in the score vector
uh the output vector of the neural
network
and calibrated in the sense that we have
preserved the global minimizer
of of the entropy regularized objective
this this shares some nice relationships
to max
the maximum likelihood objective in fact
you could see it as just a natural
generalization of maximum likelihood
um i'm going to actually just push a
little bit further in a slightly
different direction
as it turns out that once we're thinking
about convex calibrated
uh surrogate objectives to a target
objective entropy regularized expected
reward
um there's a whole space of possible
surrogates uh not just based on kl
divergence but you know perhaps also
based on quadratics and so on
what's interesting here is that you can
actually think of
composite
surrogate objectives that bring together
many parts all of which are
convex and calibrated and you can in
addition achieve an upper bound so a
convex calibrated upper bound
uh on the target objective that
nevertheless uh preserves the location
of the global maximizer
um this is very useful in theoretical
arguments about showing that minimizing
say an empirical version of this
convex upper bound will eventually imply
achieving a good
target objective
i won't spend too much time dwelling on
experimental results in this
presentation
but it turns out this is actually a
pretty reasonable way to develop
useful training objectives even in
supervised learning that in fact
do allow you to achieve some advantages
over uh naive maximum likelihood
and one reason why we even see
advantages not just in training
optimization but in
test generalization has to do a little
bit with this generalized kl doing an
implicit form of label smoothing
but i want to move on to another i think
more surprising and more recent
observation when we consider
the uh the problem of maximizing
expected reward
and that's to actually go back to the
beginning and reconsider the role of the
soft max
now i'll remind you that the softmax
transfer itself
is in a way the the key source of
optimization difficulty even when we're
targeting uh
what we declare is the target objective
excuse me
so all of the results i just shared with
you uh didn't question the use of the
softmax but instead committed to the
softmax and
instead just built proxy surrogate
objectives for the
for the training target
however we can go back to the original
expected reward maximization problem
and reconsider the role of softmax and
here it's actually quite shocking i
think surprising
that there's there's actually been some
very recent breakthroughs
just in the last year in fact in
understanding the nature of directly
optimizing
uh expected reward um agarwal at all
uh within the last year have discovered
that just simple gradient descent
optimization of this objective
actually remarkably does find a global
maximum even though this is a
non-concave maximization
in the case of a tabular score function
we've recently strengthened this result
to actually put rates uh to establish
both upper bounds and lower bounds on
the rates of convergence of gradient
descent in this setting
um and all of these results are indeed
generalized far beyond just sort of
tabular settings
to you know contextual banded settings
and even general markov decision
processes
um but what i want to acknowledge is
somehow this seems like a direct
contradiction to what i started out
saying is that this is a problematic
objective and we should reformulate it
in terms of surrogates well
what's going on here is that uh
indeed simple gradient descent in the
overcomplete setting
will eventually find a global minimizer
and we even
have rates upper bound rates uh giving
one over t
rates of convergence of gradient ascent
to global
maximizer um but what's what those
uh bounds are hiding is uh
specific constants and it turns out that
the big o like
one over t upper bound hides up not only
just problem specific constants
but initialization specific constants
so one the real reason why uh training
expected
uh to maximize expected reward in
practice is almost hopeless
is that eventually you can with enough
capacity in the neural net eventually
you can get to a global maximizer
but we don't have good enough ways to
initialize the parameters of the network
to avoid these bad cases
and you can show that theoretically for
any problem setup
there always exists some valid
initialization
that keeps the uh the results of
gradient descent optimization
strictly sub-optimal for an arbitrary
long period of time
that is for any uh problem set up r at
any time horizon t there always exists
an initialization that keeps
you far from optimality up until at
least t
time um in practice what we see is when
you look at gradient descent
minimization
or maximization of this objective is
that it is strongly attracted to
suboptimal corners of the simplex
and once it gets near a sub-optimal
corner eventually it will escape
but it takes astronomically long amounts
of time to escape
and it's it's very difficult to avoid
these initialization traps
with the softmax transfer
so in response to this actually another
recent discovery
is is to question like well why are we
just committed to the softmax so
it's true we understand that this is
like in every code base and machine
learning around the world right now
um and there are many historical reasons
that you know motivated that as a
reasonable mapping from an arbitrary
score to the probability simplex
um but of course it's not the only one
there you know once you think about
the pro the problem of reformulating a
mapping to the simplex
there's their entire families of you
know continuous smooth mappings that can
map score vectors simplex
and so uh just as a simple investigation
we consider it an
obvious polynomial transfer so instead
of exponentiating scores and normalizing
you can imagine just you know raising
scores to some power absolute value
uh and normalizing that mapping that to
a policy
this uh this mapping has been actually
uh studied in physics
uh under the name of escort transform
and it's also appeared sporadically in
the machine learning literature
what's interesting about this though is
we've found that just
replacing the softmax transfer with this
kind of
softer polynomial transfer actually
yields
not just empirical but theoretical
benefits so
uh one simple result is that if we
replace soft max with the polynomial
um okay we still get an o one over t
rate of convergence
but now we can establish that
convergence with a initialization
independent constant that is we can
mitigate the
initialization sensitivity of uh softmax
expect reward maximization
profoundly by just replacing the softmax
and what's also interesting is we see
empirically
both in simple like bandit all the way
up to mdp contexts
that this modification uh renders huge
empirical benefits
certainly in terms of the speed of
training or the speed of optimization
i find it actually quite surprising that
just now we're finding these very basic
facts
about you know the nature of the
optimizations that we're attempting
way way way down in the in the central
core of reinforcement learning before
we're even dealing with like exploration
and uh you know missing data issues
okay so uh i now want to pivot uh to
missing data just briefly now i may try
to save a bit of time here
okay arguably everything i've just
talked about excuse me isn't
really reinforcement learning often i'm
criticized and
it's declared to be supervised learning
fair enough
we could look at missing data maybe as
the key distinction between a supervised
and
reinforcement learning setup that is in
supervised we assume we see
counterfactual reward observations
for every action in every context or in
an infinite action setting like
regression
we presume that we have the score
function that allows us to compute for
every action what the what those loss or
cost would have been for that action in
any context
we're now going to consider uh how do we
cope with missing data where we've only
logged a very sparse subset
of reward observations for subset of
actions
and most practically uh really we only
ever log a single action in a given
context
and record what the reward was we rarely
go back to the same context
twice and counterfactually check what an
alternative action would have achieved
okay so um missing data is prevalent
it's a very core issue
in reinforcement learning and yet uh
reinforcement learning tends not to take
the problem as seriously as
other areas of machine learning and
statistics um but still has made some
progress
so i just want to characterize maybe a
simple way to deal with missing data
but it winds up being essentially the
default way of dealing with missing data
that's still prevalent in reinforcing
learning
and by this i mean taking an imputation
strategy that is we might imagine one
confronted with this table of incomplete
data
that the first thing we could do is
simply complete it by having some model
or using our score function to fill in
all the missing data for us
reduce the problem to now a fully
observed problem and then we can apply
like the previous optimization
techniques for the purposes of training
despite the naivety of this this
actually is a technique that's
sort of at the core of of default
reinforcement learning approaches
to make this a little more clear let me
highlight
importance corrected expected reward
maximization as sort of a default
representative of this class of missing
data techniques
now importance corrected expected reward
is actually an imputation strategy it's
mathematically equivalent to taking that
original sparse set of data
and imputing a zero for every unobserved
reward
and then taking the observations that
you do have the rewards you do see
and altering those in fact exaggerating
those by the proposal probability beta
now we will notice here that uh this
uh rescaling of the rewards does require
us to know the
probabilities with which the particular
action was chosen in that context
usually in practice if that's not logged
what you will do is you'll fit like a
maximum likelihood estimator of the
of the behavior like the action sampling
process
and then use those estimates as the
propensities or the proposal
probabilities
um regardless we could see that this is
actually a fairly
uh ham-fisted and egregious way to uh
you know complete the data
it makes no attempt to to make good
guesses about what
the missing rewards are and exaggerates
uh you know
quite profusely the the observations we
do have
why uh why would anyone consider this
well the main motivation for this is
despite this it's kind of extreme nature
it is an unbiased estimate of the
expected reward objective that is
if we consider the sampling process uh
we draw
a particular action according to the
sampling process in each context
well the the estimated reward vector is
a one-hot vector with an exaggerated
reward on that single entry
but if you average that over the
sampling process you can quickly see
it's so
you know it's a simple one-liner that in
fact you get
the expected reward vector that you
estimate is indeed the correct expected
reward
so it is an unbiased estimator but it's
actually you know quite clearly
unsatisfactory um more reasonably
in practice right people will consider
what's called a w robust estimator which
is
actually just a one step deeper version
of importance correction
where instead of just filling in the
missing data with zeros we'll fill it in
with a model guess
so assume we have a model some score
function q and we use it
to complete the rewards then on the
observed data to preserve unbiasedness
all we're going to do is exaggerate not
the
reward itself but the delta the
discrepancy between the reward and the
model guess
and an argument basically uh identical
to the previous can show that this
yields
an unbiased estimate of the reward
vector still for an arbitrary
model guess q
now this is a
significantly uh more effective approach
but it does raise some questions the
main question it raises is where
should the model come from now there's a
bit of a subtlety which is the
unbiasedness argument technically
requires the model to be independent of
the data so if we dare estimate the
model from the same data
we do actually lose a perfect
unbiasedness argument
in practice though i'd say that this
creates another problem that i want to
close up so it's typical in machine
learning
and reinforcement learning to think
about policies
and value functions or scores or rewards
is somehow living in a different space
they're
they're serving a different role we
should therefore think of them as
separate models
so a natural way to approach this is
even when we want to optimize
a policy pie that we should temporarily
hold pi to the
uh to the side and just directly try to
learn a good model of value or reward
take that
model that we've learned perhaps just
least squares regression to the target
rewards
uh take that model now treat it as a
proxy essentially a completed
data set a proxy for the real reward
function and then optimize the policy to
that
now in this setting we can see that that
approach um
is actually quite ineffective for simple
reason first that that when we say do
something like a least squares
regression to the rewards
um if we don't correct we're technically
you know
biased but also the
policy optimization becomes obviated
it's literally just
taking that score function and doing the
arg max so essentially that art max is
a stronger version of the softmax
transfer of the score function so we're
really just
learning a score function by least
squares which we've seen in the previous
context at least briefly in some of the
plots that ran by is that that's
actually not very effective
um what's often overlooked here though
uh is that uh there is
i think there is a more satisfactory way
to to approach and think about this
problem
um and it's to harken back to uh when
we're looking at optimization objectives
and surrogates and particularly based on
the kl divergences
to recognize that there's actually a way
to unify
policies and scores or rewards and
target distributions
and instead of thinking of everything in
the probability space is a separate
model for everything in the score space
we could actually think of them as
connected by a transfer say here like
softmax
and we can think of one model that
simultaneously serves both roles it can
be
interpreted as a score function if we're
looking at it before the softmax
transfer or a policy if we look at it
after the softmax transfer
this unified view actually is really
useful here
because now it allows us to not think of
the separate actor critic where we're
kind of locked in place
with a very crude relationship we can
now
train the policy in a way that's
directly informed by how the
the score function is relating to the
rewards
and in addition we can simplify the
optimization by using the previous
circuit objectives
to render more more congenial
optimization landscapes
so in a nutshell you can combine these
two parts of the
of the study into a single objective
where we simply replace the implicit
target distribution
with an inferred target given by say a
doubly robust estimate extracted from
our model
but it's still just an optimization
which allows us to
minimize some concave upper
convex upper bound on a target objective
okay
it might seem like bringing a lot of
pieces together and a little bit
unprincipled
but actually i'll just skip ahead here
this combination is
is technically sound in a certain sense
that is one can show by combining the
previous results showing that we have a
con convex um
upper upper bound a convex calibrated
upper bound
combined with this imputation process
that these two things don't interfere
and one can show that indeed if you're
able to achieve
a small empirical surrogate risk using
one of these upper bounds
that that will imply with high
probability a small true risk
under you know some nice uh technical
assumptions but pretty generic uh
technical assumptions
so this this comp this unified model
composite approach
is actually justifiable um and i will
just
uh briefly flash these by you can check
them out later um it actually does
seem to render really uh useful benefits
both in terms of training
uh uh speed and also generalization
benefits in a contextual bandit setting
okay
so i think that's all i want to say
about the the one step decision making
problem for the time being
um maybe just briefly to step back
um all we're doing here is isolating
these simple problems but digging in a
bit deeper and trying to understand the
nature
of you know what algorithms make sense
what problem formulations make sense
and uh how we might achieve sort of
empirically more effective techniques
that also have some theoretical
justification
um i still find it quite surprising that
we're still making fairly significant
progress to this
day on understanding this simple core
problem
nevertheless i'm going to take this as
an opportunity to kind of stretch the
ambition out to the sequential decision
making context and highlight another
recent piece of work where we're trying
to understand
something that's specifically about time
and reasoning horizons
beyond just simple optimization and
missing data inference
okay so uh just a brief discussion of
uh issues that arise in learning how to
make
decisions uh with sequential dependents
um so here uh just to re-ground the
discussion
uh we imagine a sequential
decision-making context so
a state here would be like a context in
the previous discussion so we're in some
context
depicted by this red node and there's a
set of actions depicted by the outgoing
edges
so previously what we'd be considering
is your you're in a context you take
an action and you receive a reward here
depicted say by a dollar sign
okay what's new and so this is exactly
the contextual bandit setting
what's new here is that in addition to
receiving an immediate award for
choosing that action
you wind up in another context that's
directly dependent on the action
that was chosen uh and if we just chain
a bunch of these together
we can quickly see that the consequences
of that initial action choice
the most profound consequences of the
initial action choice aren't the
immediate reward it's in fact the
long-term reward that you're
ultimately destined to achieve on a path
or sequence of decisions
so this creates a much more challenging
inference and learning problem
we have to now think about the long-term
consequences of decisions
uh but you know but how long term do we
have to reason
and we have to learn on finite data with
like five nightly long
trajectories for example
um to to further reduce and simplify the
problem
to kind of make the the uh intuitive
challenge clearer
i'm just going to assume discrete time
so this picture already shows a discrete
time dynamical system
that is there's discrete jumps from
state to state and
also i am going to consider a simpler
deterministic setting
the advantage of a deterministic setting
is essentially we're just walking on a
directed graph
every action is an edge on the graph a
directed edge and every state
is a node in the graph
now the deterministic setting does
simplify the decision making problem a
great deal
in particular we know that for a
deterministic system
the uh an open loop decision making
strategy can be optimal that is from
every state you can just close your eyes
and roll out a particular optimal
sequence of actions
and never course correct so admittedly
it's a simplification but it still
is a challenging problem and it allows
us to focus more on a particular issue
if you're hung up on stochastic control
very interesting problem lots to say
about it
but stochastic control is also just a
walk on a directed graph in the finite
case
where we just have an additional player
called nature who plays a
stationary stochastic policy when it's
their turn to move
but i'm just going to stick to the
deterministic setting and focus
on the issue of how do we manage
uh the reasoning horizon when we're
trying to learn how to successfully uh
you know choose action sequences in a
domain like this
now i'll try to just ground this out a
little bit more concretely in a simple
scenario another version of this
deterministic
sequential decision making is is
actually just traversing a decision tree
so another way to think about it is
i give you a decision tree you start at
the root and you can follow paths to
leaves and maybe we follow a number of
paths now
the key thing about a tree of course is
that it's it's combinatorially large
so in fact in practice if we're thinking
from a learning context
you will only ever see an infinitesimal
fraction of the possible
paths you will never traverse anything
like a real
serious fraction of this tree so the key
is
issue must be extrapolation in order to
find a good path through the tree
near optimal or good or something
reasonable we quite clearly are going to
need to be able to extrapolate the
information we get from an
infinitesimal subset of paths out to
other candidate paths that we hope are
are significantly better now quite
clearly in the worst case we can embed
arbitrarily hard problems here we can
just put a needle in a haystack one goal
a leaf and no information in the tree
and you'll never find it except by
enumeration of course
um but what we're interested in are more
uh you know
more realistic problems where there's
actual structure
on the rewards on edges in the tree and
we want to somehow uh capture that
structure and use it to extrapolate
and make good predictions about possible
rewards and paths we haven't seen yet
and use that to drive
a more efficient exploration process
okay fine now uh
to set this up a bit i need to just
ground it one step further in the
classical thinking about this kind of
problem
so uh sort of the default thinking at
some level
in reinforcement learning uh and dynamic
programming
is through this concept of a value
function and i want to dig into this a
bit because i think this
uh forces us to commit to a couple of
things we may not want to be committing
to
okay anyway value function the
definition is not that interesting so in
a finite like bounded horizon setting
we could define the value of a node say
in a tree
as as nothing but the the maximum
possible
sum of a successor path from that node
to a leaf
so it's literally defined by an
enumeration over all
you know outgoing paths and just
accumulating rewards on the path and
taking a max
similarly the edge value function or
action value function
is just defined you know by first taking
committing to an edge and then
maximizing overall future paths
not very interesting okay what is
interesting though
is uh a simple you know version of what
bellman's optimality principle looks
like
in this setting um and so there's many
uh you know important consequences of
bellman's insight
uh but let me highlight some that i
think are relevant to this discussion
so um even though we define the concept
of
value in terms of this optimistic you
know explicit enumeration over future
paths
bellman had this really nice insight
which is um the
optimum values also satisfy a system of
local constraints or you can think of it
as a local recursion
um so here we can see that the you know
the optimum state value function defined
by enumeration also satisfies a local
constraint
that the optimum value of the node
consists of maximizing only over its
immediate outgoing edges the immediate
reward on that edge plus the optimum
value function at the future
from the state that you encounter so a
purely local
characterization and and more
significantly it turns out that there is
only one function that satisfies this
constraint at every node and it's the
optimum value function defined in the
first line
similarly for the edge value function or
the option value function we have this
local consistency notion this is very
attractive
right this means that uh instead of
thinking about you know
defining these values as explicit search
we could think about trying to
learn or define these values in terms of
local consistencies
if you can achieve anything like a
reasonable value function estimate or a
value function
there is another benefit here which is
it now allows you to act
completely myopically that is the
decision making process becomes
uh one where the only search involved is
one level deep
we can now make optimal action decisions
add a node s simply by enumerating the
outgoing edges and nothing more
uh and by referring to you know the
immediate reward in the edge plus future
value or just the uh
edge value function itself so uh indeed
this is
very attractive we've kind of reduced
search
to local consistency where we can now
act myopically
and uh and this is so attractive i think
it's been an endless source of
distraction in this field it's certainly
distracted me for some decades and i
think others
but i want to draw attention to an issue
here
which is this is doing something rather
ambitious it's actually planning to the
maximum possible horizon
but it's compiling things out so that
you can act at the minimum possible
horizon
so value function is full horizon policy
is the minimum possible horizon for
decision making
what this means is of course is the
value function is compiling away
all future sequential search into a
lookup function
um and i'm gonna i'm gonna uh you know
claim that that's asking a lot maybe too
much in fact
in practice so here's here's a proposal
um what if we reconsider this but start
to
think a bit more flexibly about how
we're managing the reasoning horizons
and there are many reasoning horizons of
interest here
there is the horizon that we're planning
to so the conceptual horizon over which
we want to make
optimal decisions eventually there is
the decision-making horizon the horizon
over which we're searching to choose
actions
there is actually the horizon that we're
using when we're learning like when
we're taking sample data and we're
trying to fit a model
so there's at least these three uh
distinct horizons all of which are
important
and unfortunately the default uh way of
thinking commits to very simple choices
that the planning horizon should always
be the maximum horizon
the decision horizon should be the
minimum horizon and the learning horizon
often is just the minimum horizon or
maybe stretch with k-step returns
actually i'm going to claim this is
highly problematic in fact there are a
lot of benefits to be
gained by thinking more flexibly about
horizons
to enable this uh let me start by just
proposing this
slight you know mild generalization of
value function
uh over edges to be what i'll call a
generalized counter factual value
uh which is defined on
a sequence of edges or sub paths so
let's consider a notion of generalized
counter factual value which is the value
of being in a state say or a node s 0
and then committing to a sub path of
length l
with edges e01 to e l minus 1 l
and then just define what the
counterfactual value is
and that definition decomposes into two
parts sort of like
four in terms of bellman consistency
there's the explicit part which is the
explicit rewards achieved by that sub
path that we
observe um followed by a recursive part
which is then uh um uh completing the
definition of the value in terms of
an optimistic exhaust of future search
but not to full horizon a future search
uh from the horizon l that we explicitly
rolled out to on the sub path um up to
some horizon u so u minus l
so we have a a short term horizon l that
we can stretch out beyond one
and then we have a far a long-term
horizon you but it um but in principle
we can imagine setting long-term horizon
u to something less than the maximum
possible horizon
which often is infinite in the
definition anyway
okay so i'm going to try to argue that
this is this is really beneficial and it
allows us
uh to make progress on problems with uh
which are otherwise vexing
um first observation is that if you can
somehow learn or recover such a
counterfactual
uh you know sort of sub path value
function
it does enable a form of decision making
but now the cost of decision making is
you know is
expanded a bit by the near term horizon
l that is if i gave you a counterfactual
value function
that scores sub-paths of length val we
can still use it to make decisions
how when i'm in a state s0 um i perform
a a horizon l search over possible
length l sub paths
evaluate each under the counter factual
value function and take the max
and then once we've found the maximum
path we execute the first action in that
path
this is isomorphic to model predictive
control here just counter factor will
predictive control given a
okay no big deal uh why am i you know
why am i making a big deal out of this
law i'll try to argue it shortly
um but intuitively this is actually
really beneficial
first of all in a in an environment
that's handed to you
nobody gave you any guarantee that the
episodic horizon is a reasonable one for
that problem
uh nobody gave you a guarantee that the
clock speed the rate at which you know
states were sampled in the data was a
reasonable one to learn the problem
you're just handed a problem um and what
i'm saying here is it makes sense to
think a little bit about how we're
managing these reasoning horizons
for example why would we want a
decision-making horizon bigger than one
well we can see examples of this
everywhere in high performance decision
making like in game playing if you want
to beat lisa doll let's go or
you know kasparov at chess no one has
done this but
by compiling when they all search into a
value function and then just doing
myopic decisions from a value function
you obviously will use some search a
combination of search and compiled out
value
another way to see it is that some
search reduces the the complexity of the
compilation process of the value
function so there really is a trade-off
here
why might we not want to reason to the
maximum horizon well in many problems
the maximum horizon's really long like
infinite or you know thousands of steps
but actually the real decision-making
problem mostly is tactical
you're playing some video game on atari
and
you know there is like a multi-thousand
step horizon
but really you just want to like shoot
some aliens and hide
you just need tactical plans they're at
a much shorter time scale
um so in the interest of time i'll speed
up a bit on details maybe people can
follow up with me after
uh but we uh we started to you know take
this a bit seriously and look at
uh learning these kind of generalized
counterfactual value functions
uh and represent them in various ways um
but you might think of it as simply
learning a model so if i learn a model
of the dynamics and the rewards in some
domain
that allows me to kind of represent you
know counterfactual value predictions
what i want to point out though here is
that uh okay sorry there's a detail
there but uh
there's an important opportunity here
and it has to do
with the bootstrapping so normally when
we're learning value functions
uh we're actually uh looking for a
training signal based on
local consistency and here we see you
know the bellman
local consistency principle uh written
out explicitly here for us
um and it just says that we want our
value function to be consistent in the
bauman sense if we could achieve exact
equality everywhere it would be
it would be the exact correct function
um
but here the consistency has two parts
right there's the current
uh value there's the observable part on
the observed rewards for
or on that an explicit part on the
action
the sub-path and then there's the
recursive part the self-referential part
in the future
now the self-referential part in the
future is the source of most of our
training pain because this is the
bootstrapping
so we could think of this as a
regression problem of the left side
trying to learn to approximate the right
side
the problem is if we have this
self-referential part on the right side
we wind up with this kind of
non-stationary target we learn the left
to match the right but then we change
the right and so we get these
non-stationary targets
creates no end of headaches around
training and complexity of training
algorithms
and stability issues and so on one of
the interesting
opportunities by now thinking more
flexibly about both the planning horizon
and the decision making horizon
is we can think about useful
alternatives like for example
what if the planning and decision making
horizon are made equal
well in these kind of edge cases we can
completely eliminate the
the bootstrap and have a pure regression
strictly to the explicit part
this uh turns out to be a huge benefit
okay so i'm getting a bit short on time
so i'm going to just kind of move along
here
maybe just to a demonstration a more
concrete way to demonstrate what i'm
talking about
so uh you know a popular kind of you
know toy domain is pendulum where we're
trying to swing a pendulum around and
stabilize it in a vertical position okay
uh why this is an interesting
reinforcement learning problem
is um we in addition have a reward
function which
just strictly penalizes the pendulum for
for going around the bottom
and we can also see that there's sort of
two regimes in this problem there's kind
of like a short horizon problem where
you're just stabilizing it at the top
but then there's a longer horizon
problem where we need to swing through
the the costly part of the space now the
problem with this
swing around phase is that you're
heavily penalized
so any sort of myopic reasoning about
the consequences of your actions
quickly tell you you don't want to swing
around the bottom but it turns out it's
under actuated and you have to swing
around the body
and the only way to successfully solve
this problem is to actually have
enough of a temporal commitment on an
action sequence that forces you to go
through the pain
and to go far enough up the other side
to see that it's actually beneficial
um if you dare solve a problem like this
in the
default setup where we're planning to
the maximum horizon here 200 so we're
trying to think conceptually
of a 200 step action sequence
but we're deciding at the maximum
frequency
well the problem is the action
consequences at maximum frequency are so
minimal
and we cannot get the sufficient
commitment to go through
uh the longer paths so i've never been
able to get anything
like this close to working um
you can actually visualize the optimum
cost to go
reward to go value surfaces for this
problem starting with the
uh myopic reward ending with the
true optimal value function and we see
there's very interesting structure here
but i just want to point out that
somewhere in the middle a horizon
between 32 and 64 is sufficient
tactically to start to see
decision-making boundaries that match
the long horizon decision making
boundary
so for a problem like this it turns out
that if you cannot commit
or plan ahead for a decision see an
action sequence of length
at least 32 there's very little chance
of solving this problem
so what we're able to show is just you
know simple experiments that if you
actually control these horizons
uh up to some reasonable length 32
uh and eliminate bootstrapping we get a
very trivial form of regression
that is actually able to to solve a
problem like this fairly quickly
in fact in pendulum it solves the
problem in something like five or six
trajectories
um it's just a simple demo
um this actually compares fairly well to
even you know much more sophisticated
much deeper
state-of-the-art approaches um in fact
it
it actually is able to solve the problem
uh significantly faster
uh at least in these simple settings now
i'm not really trying to turn this into
an empirical head-to-head i think
mostly i just want to um conclude this
by pointing out that
even though bellman's reduction is
incredibly beautiful
um it has distracted us uh uh and made
us maybe too ambitious in the
reasoning horizons that we're assuming
for planning and also maybe hasn't
allowed us enough flexibility in
thinking
of their reasoning horizon for decision
making
another observation is expecting
tactical proficiency to emerge as a
byproduct of long horizon strategic
optimality it's a nice dream
but it may be a bit naive um another
observation is if we can eliminate
bootstrapping we significantly simplify
everything so it's just a straight out
regression there's almost no hyper
parameters
none of this implementation matters
detail it's a very turnkey kind of
approach if you
if you can manage the horizons um and in
fact bellman's
reduction is not the only way to achieve
max horizon strategic optimality this
suggests maybe another way to think
about is more bottom-up
like tactical horizon and build that up
in a hierarchical fashion to a long-run
strategic optimum
uh this is a way to more quickly get you
know competence in a domain
and build up rather than hope that
eventually bucket brigading you know
backups will will do it for you
okay so uh i know i'm running a bit out
of time but uh that's the end of what i
wanted to say
so i just um wanted to summarize by
saying i i just
sort of gave a few case studies of
fairly reductionist like
small investigations of subproblems of
the overall picture
of course there's many more problems to
understand certainly around the
exploration loops and so on
but i think for at least for me this has
really helped isolate
issues and has led us to be able to find
you know algorithmic improvements that i
think are a little bit more grounded a
little bit
better connected to other areas of study
and maybe a little bit more robust and
so i hope others can join us in this
pursuit
thank you for your attention
fantastic thanks very much dale that was
a really fascinating talk
um we are actually out of time so uh i
think at this point we'll stop the
recording and the youtube streaming
but uh we can keep the zoom webinar
going
a little longer if if folks want to ask
questions on the on the q
a so thanks very much dale thank you
all right so uh hopefully we've stopped
the
streaming um uh
and and there is a q a feature if people
want to ask
us questions feel free to uh go ahead
and
and do that in the q a while they're
working out how to use that
dale um uh for the last part uh
you know everything depends here on this
the planning horizon and
the the horizon of the q function i
forget what you call the
the the u um u horizon um so it seems
like
you know you get a whole set of very
different problems when you choose those
horizons differently
um the presumably you know the right
choice like the pendulum example
you know is very problem specific so is
there you know is this something
that you would advocate choosing by
trial and error what's the you know how
do you how do you find those
those sorts of yeah um so i i would say
this this particular research is still
kind of in a somewhat immature state i
think uh
clearly in pendulum you know we have so
much understanding of the domain that we
can you know pretty much eyeball
reasonable
like horizon choices um
i mean in the long run of course you'd
like the horizon choices maybe to be
adaptive
and you'd like to be able to formulate
like what what signal or feedback are
you
looking at that allows you to judge
whether or not like your
you know planning horizon is too long or
too short or whether or not your
decision-making horizon is too long or
too short um
i think you know depending on which and
i didn't have time to really emphasize
the learning horizon
uh which is the the kind of the temporal
extent that the actual parameter
optimization is running
um i think it's a bit different each
case i think the
decision-making horizon is all about the
you know trajectory optimization cost
uh in some sense you know if you stretch
the decision-making horizon out further
you can probably make better decisions
but the the problem of
finding you know good subpaths out to
that life gets you know exponentially
harder as you stretch the horizon out so
there's
sort of a computational consideration
around decision making
um in terms of the planning horizon u
that's not as much a computational
uh issue as it is a um
an ambition issue it's it's it's as if
like we could we could set out that we
want to solve
like go you know out to the to the you
know the end of the game like that
that's a fine ambition right um but if
i'm just learning how to play goal like
really that's what i should be trying to
do like
win go games like you know there are a
lot of
there's a lot of sort of you know
shorter horizon tactical
like understanding and go like at what
scale do you need to understand patterns
and how they play out and so on and so
forth
and i think that the ambition you know
if you're too ambitious
it just makes it so difficult to compile
out all of that future search into your
neural net
you know uh you know near horizon
decision maker
and so i i don't quite know yet what the
signal is but
the intuition is something like you know
we should be
dialing back the ambition until we're
succeeding at something and then you
know and then maybe
stretching it out uh you know as
learning progresses so there's a lot of
intuition
but i don't yet have clear technical
proposals
yeah i guess for the you verizon there's
also a kind of stationarity issue right
that that
that does you know if that's short of of
infinite then you do have to be
concerned about where you are in the
game right
uh what what stage of the game you're at
or something right these things are
going to change in fact the effective
horizon
is also state specific right they're
going to be easy situations to be and
they're going to be hard situations to
be in
um yeah yeah so there
there's a question posted um so there
are a few people that asked about
a reference for the um the last the last
part of the presentation
um and then there was um
a question at the end that uh abhishek
asked
about the escort transformation
um and the comparison to the more common
soft max
transformations and extending
oh sorry i think i have to scroll down
to see more oh
are there some indications of those
extending to rl
yeah i mean we've tried it uh i mean one
of the
one of the uh you know pictures i flash
by was like a four room
you know problem um it seems like it
helps training a lot uh i i think what
we've been
okay so me personally what uh for that
research what i've been most distracted
by is the detention
you know like transformers and attention
models that
embed this into attention mechanism
using softmax everywhere
um and and you can see if you look in
these architectures there is a
scaling like divide by in degree kind of
thing there
so clearly you know the inventors of
these techniques struggled a lot with
this kind of saturation and trying to
avoid you know premature
determinism in the in the transfer
function
and found a recipe that works my
conjecture is that if you just pull that
out and
plug in escort like you know like
training problems are going to be
significantly easier
we haven't yet managed to try that out
and we are meeting some skepticism from
you know the people who really
understand and use those things so
it hasn't been that straightforward but
i i actually still want to be proven
wrong there
uh and we haven't quite gotten to that
but i think the ambition
is the full one like everywhere you use
softmax
why uh and i think you will find it at
least from an optimization standpoint
it's a problematic choice now whether
there are uh detriments on the
generalization side
i i don't know and some of my colleagues
tell me like they've tried this
and supervised learning and they didn't
win you know they didn't get
generalization gains i didn't hear much
of a reaction on the
on the training costs which i conjecture
would be significantly better
um so i'm not sure you know if it's that
consequential but um in rl
i think the training costs are so
overwhelming still
that maybe maybe that would be a higher
impact direction
right um i think all the questions that
oh
no we've just got another couple pop-up
um one more have you tried mellow max of
assadi and litman instead of soft max
ah okay well uh i i know about mellowmax
so i can go that far but no we haven't
tried it um
maybe that's a a side discussion i think
mel and max is maybe interesting but
i've had some conceptual uh difficulty
doesn't quite give us the same duality
between two spaces
anyway but we could follow up offline
right
yeah and the others are all about um uh
finding pointers references to the
uh yeah the last 20 minutes uh
is a to be uh
to be revealed uh it's it's actually
ongoing work
um like we're literally just pulling it
together but but i i thought it wouldn't
be nice to have a talk without
some discussion of time fantastic
all right um thanks very much dale
thanks again that was that was a
wonderful talk
really appreciate it um thank you thank
you for
uh hosting me peter all right
you